je suis avec Aurélien 31 ans un électeur
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors est-ce que
vous êtes déçu ce soir forcément
forcément déçu vu la dynamique qui a eu
ce dernier mois sur sur la campagne avec
l'accélération dans les
sondages qui était assez intéressante
maintenant oui forcément déçu mais assez
confiant pour l'avenir pour moi c'est
c'est pas la fin de la campagne c'est
début d'e nouvelle ère où les citoyens
sont beaucoup mobilisé je pense qu'il y
a une prise de conscience qui va êtrete
qui est porteur de beaucoup d'espoir
est-ce que à titre personnel dans de
semaines vous voterez pour Emmanuel
Macron alors ce qui est sûr c'est que je
voterai pas Marine Le Pen maintenant le
chantage au Front national est difficile
à avalé depuis 2002 ça fait la deuxème
fois et j'en ai un petit peu marre donc
je réserve ma réponse encore vous nêtes
pas encore sûr non pas encore merci
beaucoup je suis également avec Mathilde
bonjour Est-ce que vous êtes déçu ce
soir ah oui très déçu d'ailleurs écoutez
écoutez on est on est toujours là on a
fait 19 % quand même est-ce que vous
allez voter pour Emmanuel Macron dans de
semaines mais par despis par despis
parce que je voterai tout ce qui est
contre Le Pen sauf si ça avait été
Fillon du coup mais là je vais voter
Emmanuel Macron effectivement merci
beaucoup des militants qui viennent
d'antonet vous l'avez entendu une
Marseillaise on a aussi également
entendu des slogans comme Fillon rend
l'argent ou encore Marine Le Pen en
prison vous le voyez ces militants qui
attendent la déclaration